[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
HADI HARIRI: Welcome to Krakow.
Welcome to Poland, obviously.
And welcome to this
session on Kotlin.
Now I'm assuming
the majority of you
here have probably
heard of Kotlin,
maybe not played with it,
have seen it a little bit.
If I got that right, great.
If I got it wrong, just
keep it to yourself.
And we'll start.
I'll show you a bunch of
different things with Kotlin.
And I will do it a little
bit differently this time.
I'll compare it a little bit
to some other programming
language.
Namely, we'll pick
Java today to give you
a feel of where and what we
try and provide you with value.
And just to get started,
this is my main function.
So you can see it up there.
And I can write hello.
And then I can run this.
And that's as simple as it gets.
So to start with, you don't
have a public static void main,
and you don't have
a static class.
You just have basically
top level functions.
As I always say, it's like
JavaScript, but in a good way.
And you can basically define
your functions as you like.
So I can say function,
for instance,
print message, and then have a
parameter here of type string,
and then print line,
and then the message.
And I can do string
interrelation here
and do whatever I want.
Now notice that
there's no return type.
By default, it's unit.
And you can omit it if you
don't have a return type.
And functions, again,
conciseness of Kotlin.
So what we're trying to do
is make functions as simple
as possible, and as easy
as possible to write,
and as concise as
possible to write.
And if a function returns an
expression, returns a value,
you can just write that as what
we call a single expression
function.
So essentially, if I do a
sum, for instance x int y int,
I can just write
that as x plus y.
I don't need to explicitly
put the return type.
I don't need to open the curly
braces, close the curly braces.
Just write it as simple as that.
Then, of course, you
can call these functions
anywhere you want.
Print message, something.
Now how does this help in
terms of what you already have?
You're like, OK, the syntax
is a little bit more concise,
and I write fun
instead of not fun.
And I write unit
instead of void.
But what does that give me?
So let's take a look
at, for example,
overloaded functions
in Java, This
is overloaded methods in Java.
And I'm going to
split that vertically.
And now take a look at
overloaded function in Kotlin,
So you can see that this
is already somewhere
where it's cutting down code.
I don't need to do these
overloading methods anymore
in Java.
Obviously, I'm putting this
outside in its own top level
function.
But this could actually be a
member function of a class.
So don't worry about
saying, where is the class?
The class is somewhere here.
The class is here.
There you go.
Now you got the class.
There.
Happy?
People think, oh, there's
no classes in Kotlin.
Yes, there are.
Anyway, so already cutting
down boilerplate code.
What am I doing?
Essentially here, I'm just
passing in optional parameters.
Simple as that.
Why do I have to
have all of this,
with all of this code over and
over again if essentially, I'm
doing the same thing, but with
different number of parameters.
And then, of course,
I can call this,
and I can say, for
example, val is here.
We'll now create a class.
By the way, val is something in
Kotlin, which means immutable,
read only.
It means that I
can't reassign that.
If you want to reassign
something, you declare it var.
My rule of thumb is don't do it.
Just declare it as val
and work towards having
read-only variables.
And then I can do is
here, and print message,
So I can pass in one parameter.
I can pass in two parameters.
I can pass in three parameters,
And the good thing is that you
can see that this is actually--
this is [? Intelliger ?]
giving me
that the name of the parameter.
But we actually have named
parameters in Kotlin too.
So if I want to pass
in the suffix first,
I could just put suffix,
and then pass in the suffix.
And then here I would say the
prefix, and pass in the prefix.
And then this would
become the actual message.
I can alternate the
order in which I
want to pass in the parameters.
And this is useful, of course,
not only for alternating order,
which why would
you want to do it?
But anyway, but it's useful when
you have multiple functions,
probably legacy that
has 200 parameters,
and you're playing a
game of true and false.
So you can start to
name those things.
Or you could refactor.
But why bother when you
can hack things together.
Now Kotlin does have
classes, as I've shown you.
I've created a class.
And one of the typical
quintessential examples
that we show is a class in Java.
So let's say customer job,
customer type, ID type,
customer Java, split vertically,
and let's show customer Kotlin.
OK, there you go.
Now, and then again, you're
going to say, oh, big deal.
Any ID generates this for me.
Yes, it does.
But the ID doesn't
maintain it for you.
And the ID doesn't
come and say to you,
oh, don't look at that,
Hadi, because that's just
boilerplate code that
I've generated for you.
I don't know if someone's gone
and modified all of that code.
So all of this,
essentially, is declared
with a single line of code.
And the data class over here,
when I add the data modifier
to it, what essentially
that is doing
is providing me with
some new functionality.
Namely, it's giving me
the equals, the hash code,
the to string, and the copy,
which we'll see in a moment.
What you'll also notice here
is that essentially, I'm
doing the whole property
declaration and constructor
also in a single line.
So here, I'm declaring
three properties.
One of them is read-only.
The other two are read-write.
And that, in turn, is also
creating a constructor.
That's the short syntax.
You can also do this
in a longer syntax.
One thing to notice, if you're
not familiar with Kotlin,
is that we don't
have fields as such.
We just have properties.
And then you access these
properties with accessors.
There's no get or set.
Or there is, but it's
under the covers for you.
When you talk Java to Kotlin,
you get the Java to Kotlin--
Java to Kotlin.
There you go, or
Kotlin to Java, you
get the idiomatic
approach in each language.
But if you're just--
you're working with Kotlin,
you can just use them directly.
So I can say, for
example, val customer
equals customer Kotlin.
And then this will be 1 a b.
And then do customer.email
equals something.
So a lot of boilerplate
code you're saving there.
Now, one other thing that you
have is also the copy class.
So here, you can see that I
have a data class contacts
and then I have a list
of type email, which
is in turn is a data class.
And if you do a copy
contacts, this in turn
is actually going
to do a deep copy.
So it's going to copy
everything for you.
So you're going to get all of
those different properties.
And you can, in
fact, overwrite this.
You can say, I want the
company name to be--
when I copy, I want, for
example, the company name
to be something else.
And then it will
default the other ones
to whatever the value is.
So you can override
the values as you're
doing the copy [INAUDIBLE].
We use data classes,
as you know.
We like data classes.
Initially, we used
to have two pools.
And we got rid of
them, because one
of the key aspects of Kotlin
is to write maintainable code.
Now, we can't guarantee that,
because we are developers.
And we can take any language and
make it completely unreadable.
And as Kevlin Henney recently
said, there's a difference.
Every code is readable.
The bigger issue is whether
it's comprehensible, which
is where we basically struggle.
But we do have
pairs and triples,
So, for instance,
let's say that I have
a function that returns pairs.
So just basically,
I can just return
pair of type string string.
And we also have triples.
So if you go beyond
triple, then we
say for you to use a data class.
So here, I could just
do pair something else.
Now, if I call this
function, how do I
access those properties?
Well, the first
one is with first.
And guess what the second
one is going to be?
There you go.
You're really
interactive, aren't you?
Anyway, so the second one
is going to be second.
Now, that kind of
sucks, because, hey,
we're talking about
readability, comprehensibility.
And what is first?
What is second?
So you have destructuring
of variables in Kotlin.
So you can do, for
example, name and email,
and then do this
as return pairs.
And now I can access those
in a much more nicer way,
giving me context and
meaning of what exactly
it is that I'm accessing.
So I could do now print email.
And this destructuring
you get when
you're working
with data classes,
you get when you're
working with pairs,
you get when you
work in with lambdas.
And notice here
that it's saying,
well, you're not
actually using name.
So that's a hint that the
compiler is giving you,
and the IDE is
surfacing for you.
What you can do is also use
the underscore, and say,
anything that I
don't use, I'll just
use underscore for,
and then just get rid
of all of those hints.
But more importantly,
tell the developer
that's reading this code that
this value is not important.
And as I said,
this destructuring
can work with anything.
So, for instance, we've got
contacts or our email class.
So I can say, this is the name,
name1, and this is the email1,
and then do exactly
the same for email.
So I could say
something and something.
So it's not only with pairs.
It also works with data classes.
And it's basically
following the convention
of the first parameter
is the first position,
the second parameter
is the second position,
so on and so forth.
Where else do we try and
improve on the boilerplate code
that you write?
So how many of you
love design patterns?
It's OK.
Don't be ashamed.
Raise your hands.
Singleton, let's see.
Singleton in Java.
Now, this is a singleton in
Java, which is fantastic.
Not advocating the
use of singletons,
I'm just saying this
is a singleton in Java.
And let's take a look at
the singleton in Kotlin.
We'll go here, and we'll
do a singleton in Kotlin.
That's a singleton in Kotlin,
because we essentially
have objects.
So much like in
normal languages,
you have a class,
a type, and then
you create an
instance of that type.
In JavaScript, you
only have objects,
and then you try
and mimic everything
you learn from another
language, and bring classes
into JavaScript.
In Kotlin, we have both.
We have objects, which just
represent a single value,
and classes.
So here, I can just
create an object,
which is a single Kotlin.
And it has a property.
And, of course,
I can access this
by just saying Singleton,
Kotlin, and property,
and then assign a value.
No, you don't assign a
value to global things.
You don't have singletons
that you can change values on.
That's a no-no.
For read-only, though,
it's kind of nice.
And notice that I'm
not advocating, again,
saying oh, well, since Kotlin
makes singletons so easy,
let me just create singletons
throughout my entire code base.
Nope, not saying that either.
What else?
So one thing that
we added to Kotlin
is the concept of a type alias,
So here, I have, for instance,
a data class, and I have a name,
customer name, and an email.
Now, notice the customer
name is actually
the same thing as a string.
But it is providing me
with more semantics.
Here, I have-- and I've done
that using this thing over here
called type alias
customer name to string,
meaning that this property
is actually of type string.
But to provide more meaning,
to provide more semantics,
I'm using the name
customer name.
But I can pass in.
It will verify this
at runtimes at string,
at compile times at string.
You can pass string where
it's customer name, et cetera,
Now, this comes in
useful, actually,
sometimes combining
this type alias
with something else,
which is called
the deprecated annotations.
And I'll show you
how this works.
So let's say that I
have a class, customer,
and we're going
to now come here.
And I'm going to rename this.
Well, actually, I'll
just comment it out.
And what I've done
here is essentially
created a deprecated
annotation that
comes with Kotlin, that
you say a customer is now
called awesome customer, and
replace with awesome customer.
And this actually doesn't work.
Eventually, it
will be implemented
so that you can do Alt-Enter
and replace that in the IDE.
And notice, that
now type alias, I'm
saying customer is awesome
customer, So what happens here
is that now when
I hover to this,
it says awesome
customer is deprecated.
I did that the wrong way around.
Awesome customer is
deprecated, and you
should use customer instead.
Now, the good
thing about that is
that this allows you to
refactor things and rename
things without potentially
breaking people's codes.
But then you're
probably thinking,
why do I care about
breaking people's code?
Let me just do that myself.
So it is actually quite
useful in that sense.
And we use it quite a bit.
You can do a multiple
phase change.
I'll rename something,
and then issue a warning.
And then on the next one, I
will remove that, deprecate it,
and away we go.
And nobody can
complain because we
don't complain as developers.
So that was a joke.
Here's another example.
Of course, it's not funny
when you say that was a joke.
So I have conditional
expressions,
Kotlin conditional
expressions here.
So for now, just let's
focus on this one.
Let me actually close this one.
And I have a string parameter.
So I'm declaring the string.
And then I'm doing if
rx length equals 0,
assign a parameter to it.
If not, whatever.
I've got another case where
I'm returning a value.
And then I've got
a switch statement
where I'm saying, if it's
case one, if it's case two.
If not, then if the value
is within a specific range,
then do this, et cetera.
Ignore that.
And it's going to say,
oh, this is always
going to be true or false.
But for the case of this
demo, it doesn't matter.
So what about Kotlin?
Where do we kind of
try and improve here?
Well, the first thing
that you can see
is that an if and a when
in Kotlin is an expression.
So I don't-- well, it can
be treated as an expression
or as a statement.
But I don't have to
explicitly declare a variable,
assign that variable based
on the actual branch.
I could just return that as
the result of the expression.
This is a single
line of expression.
If I have multiple
lines, curly braces,
then the last line
of that branch
is going to be the return value.
So here, I'm doing
value can be 1, 20,
or I can write
multiple statements.
And then the last value is
going to be the return value.
I could even return
a string here.
But if I return a
string, the compiler
is going to give me a
warning and say, well,
conditional branch is
returning a type string.
So I'm casting the
return type to any.
Any is the top level
object in Kotlin,
meaning that if you
want to, you can return
a different type per branch.
Why would you want to?
I don't know, but you can do it.
Well, there are
cases, obviously.
Now in the when statements,
similar to a case, but we do
allow a certain level
of pattern matching.
So you can see
that I have one, I
have two, which we
had in the Java case.
Then I can have a bunch of
values, three, four, five.
I can even check for
whether it's a type.
I can even check
for whether it's
an arrange and an else branch.
I can even call a function,
and have the function calculate
a value, and return whether
that's a true or false
for that statement.
Point being what?
It is very similar
in code to what
you've seen in Java,
difference being
that it's saving
you a lot of pain
when you're writing this code.
It's allowing you to be more
concise, more expressive.
And that is essentially
what Kotlin is about.
It's not about a single
feature that you look at
and say, OK, this is cool.
But I can do this in Java.
You can do everything in Java.
And when I say Java, I mean you
can do everything in Assembly.
How many of you here
program in Assembly?
Oh, come on.
Three people.
Awesome.
That's good.
Not still, no?
Well, yes, still?
No?
OK.
Now another thing that we try
to help with is Java nulls.
This is your typical
example of a Java null,
If customer's not null, if
customer.getName is not null,
if customer.getName starts with
blah, blah, blah, then do this.
Do that.
How do we solve this
problem in Kotlin?
Well, we said we
don't have nulls.
We do, but we don't.
Well, we do, but
I'll tell you we--
yes, anyway.
So by default, we don't
have nullable types.
So when you declare a type
in Kotlin, if I come here,
and I say val my string
equals some value,
and then I do my string equals
null, that's not going to work,
because it says this
type is not nullable,
If I initialize it to
null, then it will work.
You can also do explicit
type declaration in Kotlin.
But you normally don't, so
I can do string something.
That, again, is going to give
an error because string does not
nullable.
And one day, I will
write something properly.
Now, what I can do to make this
nullable is add a question mark
and now say this is
actually now nullable,
And so I can assign a
nullable type to it.
Why would you want to do this?
Again, try and move away
from nullable types.
In Kotlin, by default, you
don't declare nullable types.
However, one of the
purposes of creating Kotlin
was to be able to interop with
all of the existing Java code
that we have and you have.
And when you're
interoping with Java,
you're going to
face nullable types.
So you need to have that
question mark there sometimes
to be able to interop
with nullable types.
So in the case of Kotlin,
what we try and do
is make it a little
bit nicer to work with.
So here, you see that basically
the same kind of code.
In this case, I don't
have to do any checks,
because it's a customer
Kotlin, and I'm
saying that it's not nullable.
In this case, however, given
that this is coming from Java,
I can actually
explicitly say that this
is going to be a nullable type
by adding the question mark.
Since I say it's going to be
a nullable type, then Kotlin,
I would have to do in line
of if customer is not null,
then do something with it.
You can do a much
shorter syntax with that
by just using the
question mark here.
So that's basically saying
if customer is not null,
then if name is
not null, then it
starts with blah, blah, blah.
And if that equals
true, then do something,
So when you're
working with Java,
you have to decide whether the
type you're actually working
with is nullable or not.
I could actually remove
this and say, there you go.
I now know that this
will never be null.
So you can use the
not null annotations
that different libraries
provide to kind of recognize
whether that's going
to be nullable or not.
What you can't do is remove
that and then get null reference
exceptions at runtime,
and then say, well,
didn't Kotlin say
that it removed null?
No, because you are explicitly
saying that this is null.
And as I always say, if you
really want to be brave,
what you can also do is
declare this as nullable,
and then do customer!!ID.
And that means I don't care.
I miss my null
reference exceptions.
I just want you to
blow up at runtime.
So you can do that as well.
While you're at
that, don't start--
this is one of the main
things that people fall into,
the trap.
When they start to pore
over their Java code,
initially, they're like,
oh, well, this is null.
What shall I do?
Double exclamation.
No, you don't.
Not having nulls in the
language is actually
forcing you to think more
about nulls, essentially,
because it's not the happy path.
Normally, when we
do error control,
it's like, well, if it's
not null, I'll do this.
And if it's null,
then I'll pretend
that nobody saw anything,
Now it's saying,
what happens if it's not null?
Oh, I don't know.
So what else?
One of the things in Kotlin
is extension functions,
So what I can essentially
do is do fun string Krakow.
And then what that
will do is essentially
print line Krakow
is great, So now I
can say Poland and
Krakow are great,
So I've just added a new
function to Krakow are great,
It's only done Krakow.
Why?
Because I've written
Krakow are great.
Now what I could do
is actually reference.
This is essentially what it's
doing is adding an extension
function to the type string.
And I can extend any
type in Kotlin or Java,
So you're thinking, well,
why would I want to do this?
Again, to make code expressive.
Now I normally wouldn't add
a function in my codebase
called Krakow.
We can do something
like two camel
case with inverted
colons German style,
I could do something
like that, because you
know that in Germany, they do.
They invert things.
So this gives you,
again, expressivity.
I don't have to take a string
class, inherit from it,
add a new method to be able
to just add one more function.
This is where the beauty of
this extension functions are.
And if you actually look at the
standard library, which we'll
see in a moment, most of
the functionality you get
are in fact extension
functions over generic types,
meaning that you get a
whole bunch of functionality
independently of
the type of things
you use, whether it's
string, whether it's
collections, et cetera.
And we'll see that when
we take a look at lambdas.
Now talking about
lambdas, lambda in Java.
I have a lambdas in Java.
If I want to declare something
in Java that is a higher order
function, I say, well,
I can do it in two ways.
I can define an interface
that takes two parameters.
Or I can do something like a
by consumer, or a by function,
or a whatever, and then have
all of these different types,
and then pass in the
parameters that I need.
And then the IDE will say
to me, OK, this is a lambda.
You don't have to
implement a route handler.
You can just pass this in as
a lambda, just like I'm using,
like the using listener in Java.
Here I'm creating
a new instance.
But I can do Alt-Enter and
replace that with lambda.
You can do pretty much
the same thing in Kotlin,
except you don't have to have
the explicit type declaration.
You can just pass
in lambda like that.
And you'll see that this is
omitting the brackets, which
we'll see in a moment.
But how do I work with
lambdas in Kotlin,
and how do I declare
higher order functions?
Essentially, we're using
always the same syntax.
I don't have to know about by
function or things like that.
I just say int, int
returns int, meaning
that this is a function
that takes two integers,
and returns an integer.
And then I'm invoking
that function.
Here is a function that takes
no parameters, and returns void,
So technically,
it's not a function.
It's a method.
But anyway, so always following
the same syntax, always.
And now, it clearly says to
me, oh, this is a lambda.
I can pass in a lambda.
And when you want to invoke
it, you do higher order,
and you actually pass
in the lambda, which
we use this syntax, which is
the same if the last parameter
to have a function
is another function,
then I can omit
the curly braces,
And then what I can do is make
this multi-line, which will
make it a little bit nicer.
Then you say, why?
Well, then I can do
something like this.
I can create a function called
using, for instance, object,
which is closable,
and then have a body--
bloody-- no, body, that
basically, what it's doing
is going to invoke the body.
And then I'll do
finally object close.
And then what I could do--
imagine that I have a val
closable thing here, whatever.
We'll close it, whatever.
Imagine that that works.
And then I could
do using closable,
and then not have to worry
about that resource being freed.
Using as a statement that we
have in C# and you have similar
[? try ?] with resources, but
essentially giving you that
fluidity of feeling as if
you are adding functionality
to the language in a way that
is very expressive and easy
to read and understand,
And all of these functions,
as I mentioned, we have.
When working with functions,
all of these things
are part of the
standard library.
So, by the way, this is how
you create a very nice--
easily, you create
a list of numbers.
And Kotlin is one to 100.
And then on the numbers, I
can do things like filter.
It is less than 100.
So it is following the
same syntax as Groovy,
saying that if the function
that I'm passing in
is a single parameter, I
don't have to explicitly name
that parameter.
So instead of doing
something like x, and then x
is less than 100, I can
actually convert that
into using implicit.
And then I can chain these.
Map to it div 100,
or what have you,
So these functions,
as I mentioned,
they're basically part
of the standard library.
You can see that they're
extension functions on interval
of t.
So I have all of
this functionality
for all the different types of
collections that I want to use.
And Kotlin doesn't provide
right now its own collections.
It basically provides
a set of interfaces
on top of Java's
collections, by default,
moving towards immutable.
So when I do, for
instance, val customers
equals list of, and
then a customer Kotlin,
that is going to create an
immutable customer for me
in Kotlin.
And I can add a second
one, customer Kotlin,
and then get
whatever I want here.
One other thing,
difference with Java,
is that in Java, you would have
the Java streams over here,
streams in Java.
So the equivalent of
what I did is 1 to 100
is in stream, in
stream range, 1 to 100.
The difference is that this
in Kotlin, all of these lists
are equally evaluated.
If you want to do lazy
evaluation, then what you do
is you just write ask sequence.
And you can do that
to any collection.
And if you want to
do it to something
a little bit more complex than
a collection, what you can do
is use the top level function,
generate sequence, and then
here, pass in a C,
and then on this,
basically generate the code that
you want to, and then on that,
map it to, or filter it--
it is less than 100--
and then for each, and then
here, print line it, et cetera.
Chain those together,
One other thing that we've
tried to-- again, focusing on it
is just more compact, more
concise, easier to read.
Another thing that we
have, which is nice,
is the return types.
The return types are a way of
implementing algebraic data
types, which is useful,
where you essentially
say that a type, a
function, for instance,
is returning one
type or another.
A type can be one
The way that we
represent that in Kotlin
is essentially through
a hierarchy of classes.
But then what we do is add
the sealed modifier, which
essentially means that
this hierarchy is closed,
meaning that nobody else can
ever inherit from response,
And these are inside.
I can actually take
them outside, and then
have something like failure,
success, and response,
and then get rid of
all of these things.
And notice-- I don't
know if you see it there,
but this has gone green.
This has gone green because
that's another thing
that we have in Kotlin, which is
smart class, which essentially
means save me having to type
things over and over again.
And instead of casting
this to type success,
I can essentially just
assume that it is success,
because the compiler
has done that for me.
So these are some of the
things that Kotlin provides you
in order to be able to work more
concisely, and more fluently,
and more rapidly, and more fun.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]